en muy poco tiempo
siendo dos caras nuevas en la política
nacional
al lado de mi amigo rodrigo y nosotros
y a los más de 5 millones de colombianos
que han votado por nosotros
este día electoral queremos darle las
gracias infinitas por haber depositado
esa confianza en nosotros
gracias a todos ellos que a tu familia
para mí para rodrigo que quede claro
para nosotros dos y nuestras familias
siempre estará por encima el país muy
por encima de nuestros intereses
individuales y personales
y hoy los colombianos tienen dos
alternativas en esta contienda electoral
que se aproxima ya para el 19 de julio y
por eso al saber que nuestra posición
es determinante para el futuro de
colombia
hemos tomado una decisión que la
queremos comunicar al país
[Aplausos]
yo no hablaba con rodolfo ni rodrigo y
yo hemos hablado con rodolfo y necesito
hacerlo
y quiero expresar públicamente
que nosotros no queremos perder el país
y que no vamos a poner en riesgo el
futuro de colombia de nuestras familias
y de nuestros hijos
y por eso
y por eso rodrigo y yo
votaremos por rodolfo y por mar l en el
próximo 19
[Aplausos]
nosotros no somos ni jamás seremos
indiferentes al futuro del país y
queremos lo mejor para colombia y por
eso estábamos en la contienda electoral
buscando unir a colombia y buscando lo
mejor para nuestras familias
ya no estamos en la contienda electoral
esa es la democracia unas veces se ganan
unas veces se pierden pero la democracia
se cuida y se respeta y esas son las
reglas de juego
gustavo petro por todo lo que ha dicho y
por todo lo que ha hecho no le conviene
a colombia
sería un peligro
sería un peligro para la democracia para
las libertades para la economía para
nuestras familias y para nuestros hijos
y por eso consideramos
que esa opción
sería un peligro para el país
aclaramos eso sí que serán rodolfo y su
equipo quienes respondan por sus
acciones dentro del gobierno
y además dejamos muy claro que ni
rodrigo ni yo haremos parte de su
gobierno ni buscaremos a hacerlo vamos a
mantener
una posición de teoría y siempre
tratando y buscando de manera sensata
oportuna y coherente un ir a colombia
que es el propósito más urgente porque
es la forma de que colombia pueda salir
adelante
y nosotros lo que sí queremos
es que de corazón a colombia le vaya
bien y por eso nosotros no podemos ser
indiferentes a este momento que hoy vive
el país
respetuosamente
y agradecido con los más de 5
de colombianos de colombianas que
votaron por nosotros dándonos su voz de
confianza
y los invito a que cuidemos el país
ya que votemos por rodolfo y por mar l
en el próximo 19 de julio
para que
entendiendo que dentro de las dos
alternativas hoy es la forma más sensata
de cuidar la democracia y cuidar las
libertades
porque una vez se van las democracias no
retornan
y si nosotros tenemos la posibilidad
como la tenemos en este momento de
asumir una posición política que sea
responsable con el país pues lo estamos
haciendo justamente por nuestros hijos
por nuestras familias y por las suyas y
por todo colombia
gracias a todos los sectores cívicos a
todos los sectores políticos y sociales
que nos acompañaron
durante estos meses largos de campaña y
que nos depositaron justamente su
confianza gracias a todos los
colombianos por ese cariño que nos
expresaron en todas las regiones y cada
vez me voy más enamorado de mi colombia
y de nuestras regiones porque la
recorrimos de norte a sur de sur a norte
de oriente a occidente y de occidente a
oriente
yo tengo la gran fortuna y tuve la gran
fortuna de haber tenido un gran
compañero de fórmula pero sobre todo un
gran amigo y un gran colombiano como él
rodrigo lara a quien le doy las gracias
a él y le doy las gracias a su esposa ya
sus hijos mariana y ha sido ya su hijo
samuel y quiero agradecerle amargar a mi
esposa por aguantarme tanto estos meses
tan difíciles y tan complejos gracias a
margara por querer también a colombia y
sé que todos hicimos una labor pensando
en el país gracias a mis hijos emilio y
pedro a quienes amo y que le digo a
ellos y a todos los niños de colombia
que vamos a seguir buscando el mejor
futuro para colombia y jamás vamos a
dejar de trabajar por ella y muchas
gracias a ustedes a las amigas ya los
amigos de los medios de comunicación
tanto nacional como internacional y por
supuesto a quienes nunca se ven en los
noticieros
vistas que son quienes están detrás de
todas estas cámaras y en los televisores
y que hacen todo esto posible mi cariño
también con ustedes gracias por el
respeto y por acompañarnos
defendamos la democracia y las
libertades
y que venga lo mejor para colombia
gracias a todos ya todos los colombianos
una feliz noche muchas gracias y
seguimos adelante